well art it's a form of expression
helping our children succeed in and
outside of the classroom now many
parents and teachers say it is one of
the many forces that has kept many
students going during challenging times
sally jaramillo visited a school where
students take pride in every single
piece of art they create we have bright
yellow i have a bachelor's in fine arts
and art was really my passion liza moore
is a teacher at don darrell elementary
school she has taught art for 15 years a
dream come true honestly i love sharing
art with these kids and seeing them grow
more love seeing watching children start
with small drawings and see how their
techniques evolve over the years i do
push critical and analytical skills with
my students i'm really trying to get
them to
sort of think out of the box amore says
as a child she depended on art as an
outlet and with a pandemic she's seen
firsthand how art has changed kids lives
she wants to see it in more valley
classrooms i'm a kindergarten mom myself
and my son is always so excited to come
home and show me what he's learned amore
isn't the only one who feels this way
katherine ethington is a mother of four
she's seen how art has influenced their
lives it is a major self-esteem booster
ethington adds art is as important as
math reading and writing and would like
more funding to go towards the arts each
school each class each child has access
to fine art sally jaramillo live local
now